hey guys it's Jenna here so most of you
probably know that I have been increased
for the past three weeks I had the most
amazing time and I filmed my entire
travel there as well you got to watch
the video it was beautifully shot and
created by a close friend Adam and
myself and I have to say it is probably
one of my best videos so be sure to
click on the link in my description box
watch the video and let me know what you
think so during my long hours of travel
I like to keep myself occupied by
listening to audible there is a huge
selection of health and fitness
audiobooks to choose from and you know
what it is so convenient to access them
straight from my phone so with constant
traveling and having very little time to
read audible has actually allowed me to
keep myself updated with new and
interesting information within the
health and fitness industry I started
listening to the body book by Cameron
Diaz on audible the body book teaches
you how to love your body by first
understanding this amazing vehicle your
body so what I really like about this
book is that it's presented in a really
fun practical and also
easy-to-understand manner you can get
this book for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium box and sign up
to the 30 day free trial so whenever we
travel it is typically difficult to eat
healthy that wasn't the case when I was
in Greece I had the most amazing
Mediterranean diet for three weeks and I
have to say that it has helped me to
stay in shape so I'm sure most of you
have heard about the Mediterranean diet
and why it is also one of the world's
healthiest diet the fundamental of this
diet is really simple and it is
something we have spoken about over and
over again which is to eat real food
focusing on lots of vegetables fruits
whole grains protein and also healthy
fats what I really like about this diet
is that there is no restriction or
needing to go crazy about counting
calories so when I was in Greece I was
really impressed to only find one
McDonald's in the entire city
Center so I asked the locals they told
me that McDonald's tried to conquer
their country back in the 90s but failed
miserably
that's because the Greek people still
prefer their own local freshly cooked
food so I want to share with you my
observations and experience going on the
Mediterranean diet for three weeks and
why it can help you to maintain a
healthy weight long term and also to
lose weight the first observation is Ave
Pal on lots of vegetables and fruits
everybody knows a Greek salad and you
can pretty much see it being served on
every table as a starter having a big
bowl of salad is a great way to study
milk because it is very filling low in
calories and you will end up eating less
for your main course the Greeks do also
eat a lot of vegetables dishes some of
my favorites include briam mix roasted
vegetables stuffed vegetables with rice
I absolutely love this and also dough
mother's stuffed vine leaves which I had
of the opportunity to make so whether
it's raw or cooked vegetables make
vegetables at the center of your meals
the second observation is that fats are
not forbidden when we mention our lives
we tend to think about the Mediterranean
they love the olive oil and they will
literally have it in everything from
their cooking to salad to dipping in
bread and even to include into their
beauty products do you know what I am
really envious on how cheap it is over
there because in Malaysia olive oil is
rather expensive and when it comes to
buying olive oil there are certain tips
which I've learned so you always want to
make sure that it is extra virgin olive
oil the lower the acidity the higher the
quality so go for 0.4% or less and
always buy them in dark bottles heat and
light can damage the oil by creating
oxidation which causes it to lose all
its benefits so here's your challenge
swap your lard butter or margarine with
olive oil it is said that just two
tablespoons of olive oil every day
help with weight loss even though it is
healthy fat it is still very high in
calories so remember to consume in
moderation
the next observation is the Greeks love
to use a lot of herbs and spices to
flavor their food so as I've mentioned
before herbs and spices is the best way
to flavor your food without the extra
calories so if you want to make your
food taste good without the extra
calories swap your heavy cream and also
sources with herbs and spices next the
Greeks consume dairy in moderation Greek
yogurt oh my god it tastes so good
it is so rich creamy full of flavor and
low in calories I just love how the
Greeks use Greek yogurt in everything
from making dips to use as cream topping
on desserts and of course the best is to
make ice cream so you won't find ketchup
chili or barbecue sauce on the table
because who needs them when you have
Greek yogurt to go with everything
here's a really simple comparison 100
gram of full fat Greek yogurt has about
100 calories 100 gram of heavy cream has
345 calories so if you're watching your
waistline but still want to enjoy the
flavor of full fat cream opt for Greek
yogurt instead trust me you will not be
able to tell the difference so when I
was hiking in Madeira with a tour guide
halfway through our hike he took out his
snack box and offered me some nuts seeds
and also dried fruits and I was like
whoa you guys actually snack on this
stuff I thought it's only for the health
freaks so apparently that is their
regular snack and you can in fact see a
lot of vendors selling them by the
street so I challenge you to swap your
sugar salt and fat loaded biscuits
crisps and chocolate bars with nuts
seeds dried fruits and legumes my next
observation is the Greeks enjoy their
seafood fish port
and would limit the red meat intake so
when I was increased I was so happy to
be eating the entire fish to myself and
also lots of seafood so limit red meat
to once a week and enjoy a lot more
fresh fish seafood and also poetry but
remember that at the center of a
Mediterranean diet is still focusing on
lots of vegetables and here's the good
news for other bread pasta and also rice
lovers bread pasta and rice is a huge
part of the Mediterranean diet yep
we are not going for low carb on low
carb whenever you dine in a basket of
freshly baked bread will always be
served I did enjoy it but I have to be
honest after a while it was a little too
much for me
the bread will always fill me up before
my main course came but what I really
enjoyed was the stuffed vegetables with
rice and also dominoes which are
repeated so many times and without even
realizing I was pretty much a vegetarian
for most of my meals so carbon levels of
vegetarians you will not feel deprived
next what your cooking methods the way
you cook your meal can either turn it
into a really healthy meal that is
really good for your body or it can turn
into a high fat greasy meal and make you
feel really crappy so the Greeks rarely
deep-fry their food the meals are
typically baked grilled boiled or
roasted by just changing the way you
prep your meals you will be amazed on
how many calories you can cut down to
the Greeks eating is a daily event so
just ask yourself when was the last time
you set around the table with your
family and friends and enjoyed a really
good meal well to the Mediterranean
people probably every single day so
instead of just gobbling down your
entire meal in front of the TV for the
next week I want you to sit at a table
and give eating the priority it deserves
I can promise you your food would taste
so much better and you will be able to
tune in to your body's hunger and
fullness signal
you will know when you're satisfied when
to stop and avoid overeating and finally
they know how to treat themselves they
love their sweet desserts as well
who loves baklava there is nothing wrong
in enjoying your sweet treats once in a
while remember guys it's all about
moderation and that's what I love about
the Mediterranean diet this diet is a
way of eating it is not a formal diet
plan which tends to be restricted and
can leave you feeling hungry and crave
for more this is a healthy day-to-day
eating for long term so instead of
looking for Mediterranean recipes I
would encourage you to apply these 10
tips create your own recipes and adapt
them into your lifestyle and I can
assure you that you will be consuming
less calories you will feel satisfied
you won't have the urge to snack as
often and you will have a heavy waste
line and remember guys the Mediterranean
diet is not a miracle solution to losing
weight you won't lose weight by just
eating this wave you will still need to
stay active on a daily basis and get
enough rest do check out my Beachbody
workout series which I filmed during my
time in Greece I would also like to
thank audible for supporting my videos
so do click on the link in my
description box and get your first
audiobook for free if you find this
video to be helpful be sure to give it a
thumbs up share and subscribe to my
youtube channel for more new videos and
don't forget to follow me on my social
media channels at Joanna so official and
guys I want you to stay healthy and
happy all the best